I'm a Kentucky trooper and I'm an
instructor at our Academy the police
academy
we lost three guys last year could you
discuss how how to deal with training
these guys as hard as you can and they
still lose their lives while working so
as far as dealing with people and
letting them know that you know that
this goes down how do you deal with that
well first of all I get a lot of
feedback from police officers out there
in the world and if I would say one
thing to them to lead this office thank
you for what you do you guys have a
dangerous job it's intense it's
thankless most of the time and you're
dealing with the with the dregs of
society all day long and then you have
to balance that with dealing with normal
civilians and citizens so thank you for
what you guys do and also I'll throw on
top of that fire fighters you know
paramedics thank you guys for what you
do and again thankless job difficult job
dangerous job where people you're
helping people that don't want to help
themselves in many cases so thanks for
everybody thanks for all those those
first responders for what you guys do
yeah
now as far as training guys hard and
then you still get guys that get killed
bless them but let me ask us what is the
alternative right what are you gonna do
not train hard you know I had the first
SEALs that were killed in Iraq were
killed under my command and with my guys
Marc Marc Lee Mikey Mansoor and Ryan job
and we trained as hard as possible
and we still took those casualties I'm
telling you we trained as hard as
possible and it it wasn't for lack of
training or lack of planning or lack of
skill
it's the nature of combat it's the risk
of conducting operations in a hostile
environment and I'll tell you what when
I got back to America and I took over
the training for the West Coast SEAL
Teams that fact that fact of losing my
guys in combat
it made me fanatical about training and
I was already fanatical about training
but it multiplied it infinitely because
it now became my mission to prepare
these guys the apps to the absolute best
of my ability and get them ready for
combat in part of that preparation was
making them understand what was at risk
and I think that's something that you
should do here you know you don't know
what's gonna happen when you go into the
field and you don't know when it's gonna
happen so everything you do should be to
prepare yourself mentally and physically
for the moment of truth whether that
happens at a traffic stop or while
you're serving a warrant or while you're
stopping a bank robbery you don't know
when it is going to happen
and so you got to tell these guys tell
them the truth of the danger and let it
sink in and hound on it and I I tell
this story from time to I was I'm his
story it's a statement and it's because
I remember this feeling and it was when
I got back from Ramadi and we were doing
we'd be doing urban training and I would
see a guy like standing in the street
standing in the middle of street which
is which is not a good move right that's
where bullets fly down you're gonna get
shot if you're standing the middle
Street and it happen all the time to
guys in Ramadi and I would see a guy
that would be standing in the street and
I would literally feel sick it was only
for about maybe six to nine months after
I got back when I'd go into these
training sites I would feel sick to my
stomach and I would just feel this
horrible feeling because it was like I
was waiting for
thing to be I was waiting for him to get
shot and it felt horrible and I want my
goal was to transfer that feeling into
their heads I wanted them to feel sick I
wanted them to feel embarrassed and feel
guilty and feel angry and feel
disappointed that they were doing
something wrong because I wanted them to
change their behavior which would keep
them alive so I would say in this case
you've got you're putting people through
training valuable training and of course
they're still gonna go out and do a
dangerous job but you you don't back off
the training you train harder and you
use these guys again god bless them you
use these guys that were killed in
action as an example of hey guys this is
why we're training hard this is why
we're gonna push this is why I want you
to take personal responsibility for
yourself and for your training and for
your skill set so that you're ready you
train how you fight and you fight how
you train so take advantage of that and
be ready yet a lot of times that that
pain of you know any kind of fail in
this case it's an extreme case losing
your guys you know you guys are going
through these extreme cases and that you
know so there's a spectrum of you know
of cases but any kind of failure or
mishap that causes any kind of pain you
can and it's not easy it's not easy but
you can use that pain to facilitate your
passion in a corrective way you know
like how you say train harder you can
take that pain and literally focus on
good ways of training training hard
being attached to the results of
training you're
the process of training yeah you know
and it and it'll you get essentially you
can use that paint you know yeah so you
get a guy that's an MMA fighter that
loses to a submission hold right you got
butane you say okay but you gotta work
out jiu-jitsu you take a guy that's gets
his legs kicked out from underneath him
okay you got to work you're more time so
you take those painful training
experiences and you put them like you
said you put them to work
absolutely yeah and a lot of times a lot
of times that'll come naturally a lot of
times but it doesn't always so in those
cases you can just just actively and
consciously take that pain you know and
and redirect it you can do it you can do
that fully even if it doesn't come
natural when it helps